when I say that CS go Skins are stonking
I mean they're going to the freaking
moon with player counts exploding and
CS2 on the horizon virtually every
cosmetic encounter strike has either
doubled tripled or quadrupled in value
we're not just at an all-time high we're
at an astronomical atmospheric High
everyone and their mother is buying in
on the hype which begs the question
what happens when everyone goes to cash
out and things start to come down
[Music]
before we get into the video I want to
let you know that we have partnered with
Qualcomm Technologies and the team over
at Snapdragon Elite Gaming to explore
the world of mobile Esports if you want
to know all about how huge mobile
Esports has gotten all over the world
and how changes in phone technology have
helped that happen check out our episode
on the rise of mobile Esports you can
find a link in the description below The
Times They Are are changing CS go is
almost out the door CS2 is on the
doorstep but skins
Skins are as crazy as they've ever been
as I'm sure many of you are aware about
a month ago valve announced the
impending release of Counter-Strike 2 a
sequel to the so-called king of shooters
that would see Global Offensive ported
over to the source 2 engine now that
created a staggering amount of hype but
here's the thing player counts had
already been rising quite significantly
I might add prior to that why honestly
that's a topic for a different video
Counter-Strike has been growing
exponentially since the onset of the
pandemic and thanks to a variety of
factors the growth of the Esports scene
increased popularity in China increased
interest in fps at large skins have
become somewhat short in Supply why am I
harping on this well because the price
of skins was already encroaching upon an
all-time high before anything related to
CS2 leaks reports Etc had even reared
its head so when the bomb that was CS2
did drop they things went nuclear
because we had this shiny sparkly new
Counter-Strike that would render skins
in a shinier sparklier light sometimes
with an entirely new model everyone
started opening cases
ah
there's no way bro this is this is
actually insane this is insane look at
it imagine back to back not enough you
get back to back I shave my head okay
all right
oh my God it is not only did this cause
the price of cases themselves to
Skyrocket but virtually everything
contained within them everything from
stickers to regular ass vanilla knives
stonked in ways that made even the most
hardcore skin enthusiasts do a double
take and while the prices of certain
things like cases have cooled a little
bit the question on everyone's mind is
are we in a bubble or is this the start
of something even crazier here's the
thing
I don't know and anyone who tells you
they do know isn't playing with a full
deck what I do know is that we have seen
this type of growth before
and last time it ended very badly you
see back in 2021 the Cs go Skins
underwent a similarly staggering stunk
the surge in popularity that the game
saw at the start of covid gave way to a
hike in general interest that in turn
caused a sea of shady non-endemic
pyramid scheme investors to engage in
Mass pump and dump purchases that
basically sent the market into a frenzy
I know it sounds insane because it is we
actually covered it way back when it
happened if you're interested in
learning more the point is that because
the growth was manufactured and in that
sense inorganic it created what you will
hear economists refer to as a bubble the
schemers went to sell everyone who
invested at the behest of the schemers
got burned the bubble burst and the
market crashed
hard the way it recovered was through
organic growth as more and more people
started playing Counter-Strike so too
did more and more people start buying
selling and trading skins the market
started seeing a natural increase on
demand which in turn created an
authentic strain on Supply and over time
steady increases in price I know this is
all just basic economics but it's worth
spelling out nonetheless the question
again is is the growth that we are
seeing right now the good kind or the
bad kind well ostensibly it's the good
kind Counter-Strike is literally more
popular than ever before players are
feeding skins more than ever before and
since there aren't enough to go around
they're becoming increasingly valuable
which to be clear isn't a bubble but
what is called the law of supply and
demand so in that sense it's a good
thing
the issue is when speculation enters the
mix you see right now the player count
hasn't risen substantially enough to
justify the exorbitant increase in price
everyone's buying on the assumption that
demand is going to go up even more after
CS2 comes out which safe to say it
probably will the question is by how
much and for how long now it could be
that CS2 comes out the P concurrent
player count hits something crazy like 3
million and the value of skins doubles
what it is right now but what happens if
it only goes up by a little bit or it
goes up but only for a little while
everyone is going to go to sell all at
once to secure a return on their
investment and that my friends is how a
market goes
this is something that zipple and I
discussed on last week's episode of
unmuted for those who don't know zip is
a skin Trader content creator and
all-around expert whose opinion is
widely respected here's what he had to
say but then once CSU two comes we'll
see let's say that there is a Player
record in the start of like four million
people playing the game
we have even more new players and they
need skins as well and there is even
more reason to buy skins but then it
depends on how many like are there still
people to buy did they do it before
right and then
what I think is gonna happen is Skins
are probably going to continue to go up
a little bit and then after two months
when it becomes normal the game is
settled
people will be like okay sign the cash
out okay and that's when we see the dip
and I don't know how big that dip will
be but I I I I suspect that if we
continue climbing with all the Skins
like right now I I think it could get
pretty ugly to be clear I am not saying
that you should or shouldn't sell your
skins prior to amidst or following the
release of CS2
I am not a prophet I cannot predict the
future and Lord knows I am not offering
you Financial advice all I want to do is
offer you a better understanding as to
what's happening and why as for what's
going to happen
who the [__] knows man inventories
doubling in value overnight is great
don't get me wrong
but it's also sort of scary the future
of Counter-Strike looks very bright and
I'm not concerned that the skin Market
is like going anywhere long term this
could be the start of something really
great
I'm just nervous that short term it
could be the start of something pretty
damaging so be smart don't overextend
yourself
and yeah I'll see you on the other side
always remember you haven't made money
until you sell I think what I'm probably
gonna do is I probably have my eye on
one or two like high tier skins that I'm
gonna sell just to secure like to couch
you know a load of profit in some cases
and then I can sort of rest easy and be
like all right I'll sit on the rest